I had the sort of voice so this will
probably be a short review and you are
fine thank you this is sibling rivalry
my fellow master-builders Lord business
plans to end the world as we know it
there is yet one hope the special has
arisen I know what you're thinking he is
the least qualified person to lead us
and you are right event is an ordinary
Lego thrust into a not so ordinary world
in the lego movie on the surface this
looks like the most cliched Hollywood
film you've ever seen just done with
Legos but under it there's a lot of
great jokes there's a lot of good
characters there's a lot of wonderful
imagination great visuals and a twist
ending that actually makes a lot of
those cliches work out very cleverly
like I said my voice is soaring this one
so it might be a touch short and I'll
just be honest it's everyone's praising
it and yet it's just really good um the
characters are all really funny they're
all sort of mock-ups of the traditional
Hollywood formula the ordinary guy who's
thrown into this incredible situation
the tough chick by his side who has a
boyfriend Batman you know he's an
everything um the the wise old guy who
has the prophecy and you know blue is
Freeman cuz yeah he's in everything yes
also in Batman oh yeah actually hey
that's right it's synergy yeah and like
I said even if it doesn't come together
at this ending which we'll talk about
spoiler corner uh but even the dense or
come together with this ending the jokes
and the deliveries are still really
funny and imagination is so great on it
you wouldn't think that just with Legos
I mean I like Legos fine but you
wouldn't think they could throw this
much creativity to it and they do and
it's quick and it's wonderful pacing and
majority the jokes hit bull's eyes it's
just really good it was alright yeah
which really think loom overrated
yeah which brother think
cats in it with a straight face yeah it
was awesome everything was also it I
will say this already sorry yeah that
that damn song won't get out of your
head um I always kind of soar to assist
you better not have given me something
but get any job done I guess I sung
yesterday hmm
um I don't even know what to say like
there's hardly really anything to pick
on with this film it's no you know it's
not that there's not much to pick up but
yeah but it's like what do you it was
just fun yeah really really fun I
laughed pretty much from the start like
I just had this big like grin on my face
but I mean I just somebody played with
Legos as a kid so even though the movie
is CGI
it's incredible how they make it look
like a stop-motion film I thought it was
a stop-motion film until I started to
catch on them as computer-generated yeah
there are some things that you just
could not do with Legos and Legos can't
be that hard computer-generated make
look like one whatever but I mean
there's two the thing is there's texture
to the Legos like it's not like when you
play the Lego video game it's got that
sort of plastic Sheen but there's like
no texture to this one you you can
almost see the fingerprints as if
somebody had touched the eggs and then
worn down some in the weights and the
way they move I mean what we've done the
stop-motion with Legos I think most
people have at some point anyone with a
camera has tried it and they won't you
try yeah
and they kind of move like that so
there's times where they move really
fluently and really beautifully at other
times they'll move really choppy but
it's intentional well they did a really
neat trick which was they made it look
like a stop-motion film a by giving the
Legos like real texture so really looks
like somebody just built all this stuff
and the second thing they did was they
dropped the frame rate so it feels like
a stop-motion film it doesn't feel like
fluid CGI animation and so when you're
watching it it just looks like you're
watching a Lego stop-motion film it's
skipping frames like a stop-motion movie
would like you would see on YouTube or
something and it's just a blast if you
can't even you know I funk I
oh sure this movie was gonna suck when I
heard about it once I saw the trim I was
getting psyched when I was trying not to
like get it built up and then
everybody's okay yeah a movie and run to
me this is like it's like 95 percent and
I'm like okay don't buy into the hype
don't buy until I go in with an open
mind just don't buy him tonight but and
yeah I just it was amazing really I mean
all asti it's hard to talk about what's
good about without talking about the
ending I guess that we will go into that
in the video below this well I will say
that the comedy is I don't want to say
childish but it's got like a childlike
humor to it that's just infectious it's
just fun it's like having a bunch of
friends together making a home movie in
a good way yeah you feel like anything
can happen and everything does kind of
have it's almost so um it reminds me of
the show like home movies or dr. Katz it
feels like some of it was almost improv
you know I'm sure most of it was just
yeah the dialogue sounds very improvised
let's very quick improv and even the
stuff they put together you'd almost
where they just sort of made up on the
spot but of course they can't they have
animated and a lot of this stuff is very
complicated to put together uh
and for something like you know again
Lego the movie it's a beautiful looking
movie like oh it's gorgeous yeah I mean
there's a senior watercolor angle and
the waters literally waves animate ways
and they all have the bumps that are on
the Legos with the little Lego logo on
every single one of them and I never I
find it was like okay no this absolutely
has to be CGI because you cannot make it
anyways but the way they did it I'm like
man if you had five years of your life
to dedicate to this one scene you
probably could because they did it with
individually rendered Legos yeah so it's
which I'm sure the programmer was having
a field day with that like some fish
it's impressive from an animation
standpoint surprisingly uh and then I
think it's impressive from an animation
and it's impressive from a community
standpoint because I mean I can think of
uh and like I said the story actually
does work to but we can't
again we can't say why without ruining
it uh but even if you're watching like
that getting into the story the comedy
is so funny uh in
just how energized and positive and fast
well yeah you know it just anywhere but
kind of an without the twist it's still
one of them far it's go would have been
fun the twist gives it sort of a sense
of meaning to it that elevates it a bit
but I mean even if I'm thinking like
what if you remove the twist this is
just straight-up story I'm like I still
would have enjoyed it I love my we would
have been as deep but and I don't think
it's extremely deep to begin with but I
would have been like wow that was really
seriously I think it's I think it's I
guess it is me especially well I what's
great about it is when you think about
with this twist suddenly all the cliches
are not only okay but in a strange way
without whether you like or not in said
they're almost sanitizing planes it
actually explains the whole universe
yeah and it's really really smart so um
yeah I mean I'm trying I try think what
LZ it's just I'm doing what the I mean I
got sore voice anyway so you know we
were gonna talk for to somebody look I
told my audience on my facebook and said
it was late I said I was like it's a
little overrated
the store yeah that was fun by the
way I was like I had like so many crazy
comments like man our fan base is
pickable hey seriously were just like
out okay my fear was like
somebody's like when she's put on your
brain eat caviar you elitist Fishkin my
desk I don't like a beret without lookin
there you go nice I mean the movie was a
little elevated now I look like that guy
from The Truman Show I guess it was
Roman where you going
you're going so um but it and some
people that weird thing is though like
and I felt bad because I did out a bunch
of people who actually did think the
movie was overrated cuz they're like
thank you that's like oops uh enjoy the
terror coming your way yeah it did give
me thinking I'm like is there anything
to pick on because people like it's a
perfect movie I don't believe in a
perfect movie there's no such thing but
it is but what it is it is hard to find
so I mean that there is one thing I have
at the end again I'll hold on spoiler I
will say this the animation is so good
and I mean
grasping at straws to find things to
sort of nitpick on this movie so this is
all just like grasping but as much as I
like the animation what they did by
making it stop-motion dropping the frame
rate makes it really confusing sometimes
in the action sequences why they're
putting mimosas together it's almost
seizure-inducing well even some of the
action sequences because they have these
lasers and they're all the Lego red
antennae based lasers and when you get a
giant action sequence I mean it's it's
awesome but at the same time like it was
kind of burning my retinas I was like
hey the people I kind of rubbed my eyes
but I was like whoa yeah like when's
like a laser she is something we had is
he in complicated yeah like well lasers
shoot something that's supposed to
disappear doesn't like you know dissolve
or explore so it's just gone sometimes
so it's a your I can so so much anyway
to go as hard to get years long and
Legos are so colorful so and when you
have certain scenes where you've got
like a hundred Lego characters in a
giant fight with like spaceships or
flying things and motorcycles and lasers
and then you drop the framerate on top
of that there were times there's like
you know like I was getting dizzy like I
was like it was just visual overload but
at the same time like some of the scenes
are so good that her is like one point
is that monorail fight or whatever and I
just like grabbed you and I was like to
my job I'd say I said maybe the only I
mean at the I've in mind I really liked
it but the only thing I can think of
that maybe some people would like is if
you're casting of a humor of just sort
of stating the obvious or being
obviously dumb or serving it's a it's
very much our generation humor or mixing
certain words together even though song
everything is a it's a millennial Jenna
yeah I mean that's very important to
know going in if you're not a fan of
that kind of humor I it's all that it
was some hard throwing it at the end I
was like it was awesome to the degree
that like it was overwhelming I was like
sure yeah it is like I was exhausted
what it was that I was like this is
amazing at the same time I'm like oh
like you could have scaled back and I
still probably would have been
okay I was like damn is one of the
information overload I think if you
watch it several times you probably owe
us a lot of stuff going on the
backgrounds or sorry I until there's a
lot stuff I did catch you know so so you
do it to see it again I guess what makes
it so great and probably profitable uh
uh so yeah uh really liked it really
enjoyed it go see it
yeah I can't and just let's just recap
here how do you think this is going to
be one of the best films of the year for
entertainment value for what you're
going to hang this here
yeah so let's let's get this straight in
February we've already seen one of the
best quote-unquote summer blockbuster
style movies and it was about building
blocks Hollywood what's what's going on
what's going on you're getting beaten by
movies about building blocks bricks
bricks our plan is to eating bricks are
more entertaining than anything Michael
Bay's put out in the past ten years and
they transform better to gets more
better
so yeah just good movie go check it out
I'll do it just you'll have a blast so
I'll let see it again I might say it
again - this might be one of the few
films I see again actually oh so tan you
like house so I'm going to go Batman I
what you can be Wonder Woman like a
Wonder Woman no no I want to be that
little like unicorn thing that was a
good kitty good yeah
totally go batshit crazy I think was
awesome that thing was awesome
cuz everything is awesome everything is
awesome you're gonna be sick of that
song yeah you will